bolivia sufre con el repunte de
contagios y una de las peores tasas de
mortalidad del mundo por el coronavirus
eso no significa que el sector médico y
el gobierno de luis arse estén
trabajando mano a mano necesitamos
personal los frenos los médicos y las
enfermeras están triplicando sus turnos
aquí como usted cree que no se van a
enfermar no hay terapia intensiva no hay
es no es de tiempos necesitamos ayuda y
que el pueblo sepa sepan todo lo que
está pasando los dirigentes de los
médicos acusan al gobierno de arte de
tener un doble discurso al aprobar una
ley de emergencia sanitaria que
restringiría sus derechos y firmamos hoy
día un acuerdo todo bien pero ahora
ahora que pasó estaban allá sacando con
la ley qué
se acababa con todos los derechos
gremiales con todo el derecho a la
protesta con todas las reivindicaciones
por los huérfanos las viudas el gobierno
ha defendido la ley de emergencia
sanitaria para afrontar la pandemia y
plantea que la población se pronuncie
sobre la misma será que está mal contar
con una ley que regule los precios que
abusivamente han sido cobrados en una
prima en un primer rebrote de la
pandemia será que es mala una ley que
establezca que no se puede realizar
movilizaciones mientras dure la pandemia
mientras se declara una emergencia
sanitaria
bolivia tiene uno de los sistemas
sanitarios más frágiles de la región aún
más debilitado por el desacuerdo entre
el gobierno del movimiento al socialismo
y los sindicatos médicos
tradicionalmente de posiciones
conservadoras una disputa que ni
siquiera la pandemia ha logrado resolver